y
[Música]
en venezuela el chavismo se impuso en
los comicios regionales al conseguir las
gobernaciones de 20 de los 23 estados
que se suman a 205 alcaldías la jornada
estuvo marcada por la abstención y por
denuncias de irregularidades analizamos
el tema en minutos aquí en france 24
en chile se concentra ya toda la
atención en las posibles alianzas los
respaldos también que puedan recibir los
dos candidatos que pasaron a la segunda
vuelta presidencial que será disputada
el 19 de diciembre entre jose antonio
kast de la extrema derecha y gabriel
boric de la coalición de izquierda
con motivo del quinto aniversario de la
firma del acuerdo de paz entre el
gobierno de colombia y la antigua
guerrilla de las farc les presentamos
una serie de reportajes especiales en
esta entrega hablaremos de las
comunidades indígenas veremos cómo se
renovó su esperanza y qué ventajas
trabajó para ellos el nuevo pacto
alcanzado
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález estamos en vivo desde nuestros
estudios en bogotá en colombia vamos a
comenzar en nuestra región en américa
latina' exactamente en venezuela en
donde el chavismo consolidó el poder en
las elecciones regionales celebradas
este domingo el oficialista psuv se hizo
con el control de 20 de las 23
gobernaciones de ese país la oposición
solamente ganó en los estados de zulia
nueva esparta y cojedes el peso también
consolidó su poder a nivel regional al
obtener la mayoría de las alcaldías que
estaban en juego el secretario de estado
de eeuu anthony blinken aseguró que las
elecciones en venezuela no reflejan la
voluntad del pueblo a pesar de que el
proceso electoral contó con la presencia
de una misión de observadores de la
unión europea por primera vez en 15 años
hay desconfianza en algunos sectores por
este proceso electoral la abstención fue
sin duda alguna la gran protagonista de
esta jornada así lo evidencian los datos
oficiales que indican que participó el
41,8 por ciento
electoral
vamos a analizar y hacer balance de este
tema está con nosotros el señor héctor
alemán él es jefe de la misión de
observadores electorales de la comisión
regional en venezuela por la conferencia
permanente de partidos políticos de
américa latina y el caribe señor alemany
gracias por estar con nosotros aquí en
france24 y comienzo haciéndole la
pregunta básica fue transparente este
proceso electoral podemos confiar en
estos resultados que han presentado las
autoridades allí
si yo pienso que sí yo creo que sí por
primera vez muchos años ha habido la
posibilidad de la verificación
previa durante el posterior del proceso
aquí estuvo no solamente la europea con
una delegación
muy grandes con más de tres meses de
anticipación el diseminado en el país
sino que también tuvo la instancia de
verificación electoral de naciones
unidas estuvo también muy activo el
centro carter
estuvieron otras importantes
organización de verificación a distancia
desde en horas de selecciones como la
del mercosur o la del parlamento
argentino la de otros parlamentos
regionales
y como nosotros también en una hora una
ong norteamericana
todas hemos compartido durante las
últimas dos semanas la de judía la
observación y el acompañamiento al
proceso electoral
señor señor alemany qué garantías les
dieron a ustedes como observadores las
autoridades electorales de venezuela
hago esta pregunta porque a nivel
internacional hay mucha desconfianza en
cuanto a la institucionalidad de este
país la dependencia o independencia de
los poderes en este caso el poder
electoral allí
es normal es lo puede ser todo lo que ha
pasado en venezuela en todo lo que se
sabe que ha ocurrido en la crisis
venezolana pero creo que es importante
advertir que él y nieta oportunidad
nosotros los a quienes en diciembre del
año pasado en las elecciones
parlamentarias hay algunas diferencias
entre unas elecciones a otras por
ejemplo en esta elección surgió de un
acuerdo en una mesa de concertación
antes del viernes la oposición y en la
que hace una recomposición del consejo
nacional electoral incluso con
aprobación de los partidos de oposición
y recomendaciones de los partidos de
oposición de manera que eso le da mucha
más confiabilidad al árbitro se
electoral primero segundo el método de
elección automatizado un mecánico a
través de mi máquina que tiene una
auditoría no una son 16 auditorías
antes durante y después del proceso con
una instancia de autoridad
particularmente novedosa que no hay en
otros países que son 10 académicos
escogidos por los partidos políticos
para poder darle auditoría adicional al
proceso claro que es una garantía
adicional que no conozco por lo menos yo
y lo que aquí hemos estado y hemos
conversado entre todos los acreedores
todas las instituciones organizaciones
que éste de comentado que hemos visto en
otra realidad de electorales señor
alemany que la lectura puede hacer usted
de la participación que no superó el
41.8 por ciento de los votantes este es
un mensaje claro de la sociedad
venezolana frente a este proceso
electoral a las autoridades al contexto
político como lo lee usted
volver a llevar la lectura de esta
realidad tenga efecto obviamente que en
américa latina y hay ejemplos de
votaciones importantes altas votaciones
como como mucho tradicional sin embargo
cuando se trata de elecciones y canales
digitales no esperamos nunca un
concentraré como cuando se trata de la
repetición
del poder presidencial y cuando no miran
en el histórico de votación para el
palabras para él para botas de
elecciones regionales
entre un 40 y un 50 por ciento y no es
nada
que esperamos nosotros advertir como una
gran abstención
obviamente después de todo lo que ha
pasado en venezuela es muy normal que
haya muchos venezolanos
decepcionados cansado que hayan decidido
sencillamente no voy a votar pero si es
el domingo pero las elecciones en chile
se diseñará alemán para presidente
tengo muy claro el porcentaje pero creo
que no llego al 50% exactamente sí señor
alemany le agradezco mucho haber estado
con nosotros aquí en france24 poner en
perspectiva este tema y analizarlo para
la audiencia de france 24 en
latinoamérica vamos a cambiar de tema la
profunda polarización en chile como lo
estamos mencionando quedó aún más en
evidencia con los resultados de las
elecciones presidenciales el candidato
de la ultraderecha josé antonio kast y
de la coalición de izquierda gabriel
boric buscarán alianzas también sumar
votos y los respaldos pertinentes para
disputar la segunda vuelta que está
prevista para el 19 de diciembre fecha
en la que se conocerá quién va a ser el
sucesor del presidente sebastián piñera
manuel acá no tiene los detalles
se avecinan nuevas alianzas tras
conocerse los resultados de la primera
vuelta de las elecciones en chile las
dos orillas del espectro político la
izquierda representada por gabriel boric
y la ultraderecha por jose antonio kast
buscarán coaliciones que les permitan
ganar la segunda vuelta el 19 de
diciembre con el fracaso de los partidos
tradicionales en los comicios cobra
especial interés quien se llevará los
cerca de 900 mil votos que obtuvo el
político independiente franco parisi
boris que ha apostado por un discurso
más moderado ya le hizo un guiño a sus
seguidores a los votantes de franco
parisi queremos hablar con usted y
queremos decirle queremos decirle a
todos quienes le temen a la delincuencia
que vamos a estar que vamos a estar con
ustedes
por su lado kast afirmó que en los
próximos 27 días buscará unir proyectos
sin bajar el tono a sus acusaciones
contra el candidato izquierdista
personas son las que tienen que elegir
un modelo y van a hacer dos modelos de
sociedad distinto un modelo que tiene el
totalitarismo y que nos va a llevar al
fracaso y nuestro modelo que quieren la
libertad y nos va a llevar al desarrollo
eso lo va a decidir la gente
a pesar de que la ultraderecha se hizo
espacio en la cámara de diputados con 15
escaños por primera vez desde el regreso
de la democracia y la alianza pro
dignidad de boris se quedó con 36
escaños ninguno de sus partidos tendrá
una mayoría en el senado donde se
renovaron 27 de los 50 escaños se
repitió la polarización que marcó las
elecciones sin una mayoría clara entre
la izquierda y la derecha dejando un
escenario aún más incierto para quien
llegue al palacio de la moneda el
próximo marzo
en colombia el ex candidato presidencial
oscar iván zuluaga fue designado por el
oficialista centro democrático como
candidato presidencial para los comicios
del 2022 soloaga de 62 años buscará la
revancha en las urnas tras perder en las
presidenciales del 2014 que fueron
ganadas en segunda vuelta por el ex
presidente juan manuel santos
[Música]
y con motivo de la conmemoración de los
cinco años de la firma del acuerdo de
paz entre el gobierno de colombia y la
antigua guerrilla de las farc les
presentamos una serie de reportajes
especiales en esta ocasión hablaremos de
las comunidades indígenas seriamente
afectadas por el conflicto armado tras
el pacto del 2016 sirvió para renovar la
esperanza de estas comunidades cinco
años después cuáles han sido los avances
lo vemos en el siguiente reportaje
tuve sus disparos mi hermana que hizo
así así como que abrazar y se cayó y
cayó la cabecita así de paca bueno yo le
digo nos haría me escuchas yo le digo
que aparecía la cara si me escucha
con suspiros buenos días
defender el pozo con el que su familia
regaba los cultivos de café le costó la
vida a la lideresa indígena misa cna
zaira calambás ese mismo agua la usaban
grupos armados para irrigar cultivos
ilícitos de coca su sentencia de muerte
entre páramos atravesado por el río
piendamó está el resguardo misak de
guambía pero velasco su gobernador
explica los motivos del incremento de la
violencia líderes sociales que tienen
que ver con primero pues con la puesta
en marcha de las agendas de los
territorios con las agendas de de
cumplimiento el acuerdo de paz y en
especial con los incumplimientos
históricos de que ha hecho el gobierno
desde la firma de los acuerdos de paz en
2016 1260 líderes sociales han sido
asesinados en colombia según la ong
indepa en el cauca el 50,9 por ciento de
los fallecidos eran indígenas las
poblaciones étnicas cada vez más
están siendo desplazadas en nuestros
últimos cinco años la incrementación del
conflicto armado por diversos actores
sea la del estado la de la guerrilla y
otros actores no identificados pues se
están concentrando en inmediaciones o
dentro en los territorios indígenas o
campesinos la recuperación pacífica del
territorio ancestral es su forma de
resistencia de la estrechez de tierra
debido al incumplimiento de la reforma
rural integral y el fondo de tierras
destinadas a su reparación con tan sólo
el 33 por ciento implementado vamos a
hacer la reforma agraria desde los
territorios entonces para que nuestros
jóvenes no se caigan por ejemplo los
jóvenes han ido a raspar coca a procesar
coca bueno por falta oportunidades en el
conflicto armado sigue haciendo mella en
la juventud del campo colombiano luz
dary maestra y secretaria del resguardo
habla de reclutamiento no hay como ese
apoyo en la parte agraria y por lo mismo
pues los jóvenes nuestras mujeres
pues buscan otras otras otras formas de
resistir y es ahí donde donde están
estaba bien el conflicto armado bien en
grupos armados pues que les prometen o
les dicen que por aquí es el camino y se
los van llevando de la paz desde la
cosmovisión de los indígenas pasa por el
respeto a la vida y la tierra algo
todavía lejano en colombia
hablamos ahora de deporte pese a que el
comité olímpico internacional quiso
enviar un mensaje de calma tras una
videollamada con la tenista china peng
shuai el presidente del coi thomas bach
la w tea que es la asociación femenina
de tenis afirmó que esto no es
suficiente para determinar el buen
estado de la deportista
y franklin el comité olímpico
internacional está entrando en aguas
peligrosas deberían tener mucho cuidado
de no participar en ningún encubrimiento
de posibles violaciones de derechos
humanos en el pasado hemos visto varios
casos similares en los que las personas
no tenían más opción que decir lo que se
les había dicho es signo de leicester
que conexión a tu ser el llamado entre
el comité olímpico internacional y peng
shuai es poco convincente de que pensó
ahí tenga plena y genuina libertad de
expresión libertad seguridad y
movimiento es en quien el ritmo de
expresión
liberty security and women's y las
autoridades de la isla de la palma en el
archipiélago canario en españa enviaron
a un confinamiento riguroso a unas 3.000
personas debido a la erupción del volcán
cumbre vieja por tercera vez en los
últimos dos meses el rápido avance de la
lava de este volcán arrasó con una playa
y alcanzó también las aguas del océano
atlántico debido a la diferencia en las
temperaturas entre el magma y el agua
del mar el choque provoca una nube de
gases tóxicos que es nocivo para los
residentes de esta instancia
y con esto llegamos al final de las
noticias ya viene la economía siga con
nosotros
[Música]